okay so this is far enough for us to
start working through this together
again this is the part that's the same
it's the same volume okay but instead of
slicing perpendicular to the axis of
rotation
what am which direction am I enjoy at
this time parallel okay that means I'm
going very cool like so and of course
with these areas I'm still going around
in the same direction so I'm going to
draw it off onto the right just like I
did before when you do this rotation
you're going to get this guy forming a
cylindrical shell aren't you okay so
let's draw that it looks like
okay are you starting by the way to get
a little bit better and drawing your and
your slices and your cylindrical shells
takes a bit of getting used to but you
can see how powerful it is
so here's my shell what do we need to
put on just like before I need some
measurements it's a measurements to work
it out this thing let's start with the
easy ones what is the thickness of my
cylindrical shell dr. X because it's a
week literally going horizontally what
other distances do I need for this guy
okay so once I get the radius that is
going to tell me the circumference
that's what I needed for right what's
the radius in this case ah this is the
radius here corresponds to the radius
here that's kind of nice if you getting
yourself in the position where you're
like oh I tried one I got wrong the
radii of these things are the same kind
of thing right so the radius is still X
what was the other piece information of
units
I need the weight hold on I've got the
radius I need the height of this
cylindrical shell all right because
remember what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to slice this down the middle and I'm
gonna unfold it and make that rectangle
do you remember that so this is gonna
give me two PI R right which will give
me that length and then I need this hi
okay what's the height the height is
just how far up do you go which is the
it's the y-coordinate is it not the
height is just Y which of course I know
is just cause X okay and by the way the
reason I know that I don't just write a
check of life I'm gonna go to cons X's
because look Delta X that means you're
integrating with respect to X assume
this is in terms of X I need everything
in terms of X okay I'm ready the volume
is equal soon I'm gonna add up all of
these cylindrical shells so the limit as
what
Delta X is approaching zero I'm summing
that this time I'm something with
respect to X so one of my battery's good
zero PI on two and then what you've
gotten here if you recall this is going
to be 2 PI R all the way around
and this is going to be H so in fact I'm
even going to write that 2 H that's the
area of your cylindrical shell but then
of course it has a thickness doesn't it
namely Delta X so now I'm ready I'm
gonna write this out as an actual
integral no right what costs that can I
take out its you pay very good I'm
integrating from naught to PI on to and
what's left inside
yeah there's our H and that's X and cos
x so I've just got this now admittedly
this is still not a oh yes of course
right but we've been far enough through
integration to know all right this might
not fall out straight away but
thankfully conveniently this is not that
hard to do with integration by parts can
we simply can we do this together
what are our it's been a bit a while
maybe but we're looking for a new and a
DV that I go into give us a do you and
Ave tresses
you equals x now why is that an obvious
twist in this case it's pretty
straightforward
okay because it gets simpler whereas if
you put X here it's going to get worse
yes so I know this has been a while but
at least the contest up Tony that's
going to be one so that gives me cos x
over here which gives me good excellent
okay so now I'm ready to evaluate this
volume that volume is going to do 2 pi
outside for okay I've got the UV and
remember this is a definite integral
right so here's view V X sine X and
where is it evaluated from naught to PI
on to going forward
ok and then I'm taking away the integral
same boundaries all it's just it's just
sine X isn't it well sine x times 1 ok
close bracket and even though I still
got a little bit of language to go this
is the more bad it's just not bad
okay let's fish this out so that's in
anyway in a really upper boundary PI on
2 times sine pi/2 what which sine pi/2
is just 1 so that gives me PI over 2
take away 0 times whatever well 0 times
0 ok so that's that done with ok now I'm
ready to do this this is a minus sine X
so I might as well turn that into a plus
cos x do you agree with that from
multiply on to and now I've just got to
tidy up a little bit ok where we going
to point to the closet pound 2 is just
plus 9 to 0 and then co 0 is not 1 yeah
what about my side right is all good
I'm just going to do one more thing I
see there's a two there and then
dividing by two there so I'm just going
to chuck that in sign that leaves me
with a PI on the outside pie there's and
a -2 and dying okay now let's just pause
and see where we went right we looked at
this volume and because we looked that
familiar with this it's not immediately
obvious I don't think it's not to me
which one you should choose and they
won't necessarily tell you right but it
doesn't take us long to realize as soon
as even is it even there's a to the
student as soon as you look at this and
you say okay V equals PI not to I've got
to have Y boundaries because I'm around
the y-axis right not too wide this Y
sorry you look at that and you're like
oh right
so you're directly waste much time away
in fact you could probably do that
without even drawing the diagram you can
see that's not a bad way to go
right so you had done this part it
brings in your understanding of
integration by parts and out pops now
just as an Ender as a little epilogue
like I said this thing can be integrated
I didn't integrate it but I found out
what the integral was this is what you
get the integral of cos minus y square
will give you okay there's a PI out the
front and this is what you end up in
okay like I said I didn't say what's
gonna be fun now the lovely thing about
it is well firstly you like oh my
goodness okay where do you think this
came from by the way what do you think
it came from it came from by pons the
giveaway the giveaway that came from
bipods is this guy over here do you see
that oh that must have come from the
integrand right that's exactly what
happened like it's it's gonna come from
one of these guys right once once you
evaluate it okay now I actually you can
crunch the numbers actually even though
it looks like an awful mess because of
things like this that things like this
the zeros and ones actually do come out
in the washer you really want to test it
out you still get 2 pi times pi - uh
yeah you get it you got a few different
things in there but if you lucked out
but clearly shells is a superior method
and you can see that it was as soon as
you start to get to this expression
you're like no no no this copy it it's
copying it I'm gonna go in another way
okay